Growing up in the open seas, there are stories told of the monsters that lurked below,
deadly Leviathans, monstrous serpents, yet no giant could hope to match the lethal efficiency
of one such creature, equal in elegance incarnate, so alluring yet so deadly, so hypnotically fatal
as the siren, the succubi of the sea, the witch of the waves, the black widows of the, uh, black sea,
a maiden with a hypnotic gaze that warped the wills of even the most salt-seasoned captains,
and a song that commanded the crews of even the most loyal sailors.
My mother would read me these tales before bed, tales of aquatic femme fatales that lured men to
sail themselves to their blood-soaked watery graves. These horrific tales of nautical nefariousness
would keep me up at night. They made me feel so, so inspired. I mean, my people used to do that?
That's so cool. I mean, I've never fed on a human before, and the smartest thing I've ever hypnotized
is a seal. But learning that my ancestors used to eat humans by the literal boatloads was amazing.
I couldn't wait to grow up and eat my fill, fat ones, tall ones, skinny ones, even hairy ones.
Though I learned our people aren't as feared by humans as they once were. My ocean, my home, humans
to fail it with their presence. Worse still, they tossed their filth into it, further insulting us.
How could this have happened? How were we brought so low from our past? They used to tell legends on
every port that made even the most straight-laced superstition scoffing marines keep in the back
of their minds. They would dedicate figureheads of their ships in respect to our beautiful yet
delicate bodies. They put us on every map. But now? Ugh, disgusting humans.
One night, I envisioned a genius plan, the first strike in my crusade against the human world.
I would infiltrate in hijack a fishing vessel and use it as my own pirate vessel with a crew of
hypnotized thralls. I was going to wage a once siren war against all of humanity. It was going to
be perfect, and I definitely would have won. That was until I envisioned a plan that was even more
perfect. Er, well, at least more time efficient. Making my way below deck, I made a strange discovery.
The humans were hypnotized by their own choice. I couldn't believe it. I looked at boat after boat,
these humans charmed like a siren's spell, even dedicating their lives to their chosen idols.
These idols they fawn over were these sirens too. That's it. That's the secret to defeating the humans.
I'm going to find the secret to their magic and harness this power myself and bring power back
to my people. I must gather fame, fortune, scandals, anything and everything to grow my influence over
mankind to bring sirens back into the minds of the people. But I'm not just going to tip the
scales. I'm going for complete domination. Every human will bend to my will. All will be cheering
for their own demise. I will be the instrument of karmic justice. The world will worship me and
praise my name as I bring about their end. I will march every human under my control into the ocean,
and my people will chant my name as they have a feeding frenzy that has written into legend.
Though that's a very long-term goal. With every big venture, whether business-wise or lifestyle,
every big undertaking starts small scale, right? Hmm. So, I think I'll start with you.